i want to switch gears and talk a little
bit about decision making uh which is
kind of what you get paid to do both as
an investor and the ceo of angel list
you're kind of paid to be right when
other people are wrong do you have a
process around how you make decisions
yeah so decision making is everything
and in fact someone who makes decisions
right eighty percent of time instead of
seventy percent of time will be valued
and compensated in the market hundreds
of times more
uh and i think people have a hard time
understanding that but that's a
fundamental fact of leverage if i'm
managing a billion dollars and i'm right
you know ten percent more of the time
than somebody else and that's a hundred
million dollars worth of value on a
judgment call and with modern technology
and large workforces and capital our
decisions getting leveraged more and
more so so if you can be more right more
rational and that's one of the reasons
why i love your blog because it really
focuses on helping you be more right
better decision making more rational
then you're going to just get non-linear
returns in in your life so decision
making is everything uh and decision
making what what what what's going on
we're basically what the brain is a
memory prediction machine it has a
memory of things that work in the past
and what it's read and it's trying to
predict the future and a lousy way to do
memory prediction is x happened in the
past therefore x will happen in the
future it's too uh based on specific
circumstances so what you want is you
want principle you want mental models so
the best mental model that i have found
have come through evolution game theory
and charlie munger who i'm sure you
quote a lot on your blog but charlie
munger who's warren buffett's uh partner
very good investor but he has tons and
tons of great mental models nassim talab
has great mental models
the benjamin franklin had great mental
models so i basically load my head full
of mental models
but then different ones apply to every
situation so i don't really run a
checklist
but for example i studied a lot of
complexity theory when i was younger um
it's a it's a field that i got into i
got into
occasionally just getting these things
and i just learned a lot about that
field um and uh my most recent one is
cryptography but um i was really into
uh into complexity theory back in the
mid 90s and the more i got into it the
more i understand the limits of our
knowledge and the limits of our
prediction capability and that's been
super helpful to me so that has helped
me come to the system
that operates in the face of ignorance
and i believe that fundamentally we are
ignorant and very very bad at predicting
the future so i don't look for
and i i don't believe that i have the
ability to say what is going to work so
rather what i try to do is i try to
eliminate what's not going to work
so i think being successful is just
about not making mistakes it's not about
you know having correct judgments it's
about avoiding the incorrect judgments
um so i have mental models around
how do i determine if i can trust
somebody
around uh you know what what are the
actual odds this is going to work how
much margin of safety do i have if it
works out you know the
angel bets and venture bets are great
because they've not linear outcomes in
the positive but on the downside you can
only lose one x but on the upside you
can make 10 000 x so i tried to rig the
game so i don't believe in specific
goals scott adams says famously also
set up systems not goals so use your
judgment to figure out what kinds of
environments you can thrive in and then
build a system to create that
environment around you so that you're
statistically likely to succeed
uh i don't i'm not going to be the most
successful person on the planet nor do i
want to be i just want to be
the most successful version of me
while working the least hard possible
right i want to be like in a thousand
universes naval is successful 999 he's
not a billionaire but you know he's done
pretty well in all of them right
um so whatever the metric is or he's
happily married in most of them um he
may not have you know nailed it in every
regard but he set up systems such that
he's failed in very few places
so
so basically i just try and set up good
systems and then the individual
decisions aren't that don't don't matter
that much
because i think our ability to make
individual decisions is actually not
great so for example as an investor i
would rather invest i would rather
my system is i want to see 10 000
companies and i want to pick
500 that have a shot of being huge and
then i want the option to double down on
the five winners i don't want to just
look at 100 companies and pick 10 that i
think are winners and go all in on those
right because i don't think i have that
capability and i think there's a lot of
exposed factor reasoning and
uh and
sort of origin stories that people make
up about why they were successful
but the real separation here is you look
at which people are consistently
successful especially in silicon valley
there are lots of one-hit wonders but
how many people consistently seem to do
something interesting
build something interesting make money
and do something new
i'm not i'm not in this to make money
money is just a piece of paper and every
time i see one of these billionaire
founders you know giving away to a
hospital or whatever you know they
overshot they don't need that much money
right so there's huge diminishing
returns to money after a certain point
um especially now that i'm more into
freedom from rather than freedom to the
thing i want to do that i can't do
so literally
money in that sense is a boat anchor
around my neck because all it is
something that i've been fearful of
losing something i'm getting the
jealousy debates about something people
want from me
so i'm not even anymore for the money
it's like can i do something interesting
and new
can i create something brand new the
world has never seen that it gets value
out of that it uses that is congruent
with my morals
so i never have problems sleeping at
night and i never have to worry about
selling something that i wouldn't buy
so much more into that but i i don't i
don't have a checklist system for
decision making i know that's like a big
thing recently i told god one day wrote
the checklist manifesto and that's good
for pilots and surgeons um i don't think
it's necessarily great for
uh investors oh yeah i think he totally
misses the point of decision making i
agree and by the way that's another one
of those books where you just read the
first chapter when you're done
it would have made a great blog post
but uh yeah so i i also don't think you
need to be that hard on yourself right a
lot of a lot of what goes on today is a
lot of your listeners
are right now like beating themselves up
and scribbling notes and saying i need
to do this and i need to do that and i
need to do no you don't need to do
anything
you know all you should do is what you
want to do and if you stop trying to
figure out how to do things the way
other people want you to do them then
you get to listen to that little voice
inside of your head that wants to do
things a certain way and then you get to
be you and no one in the world is going
to beat you with being you you're never
going to be as good at being me as i am
and i'm never going to be as good at you
being you as you are so certainly listen
absorb but don't try and emulate it's a
fool's errand
instead each person is uniquely
qualified at something they have some
specific knowledge capability and desire
that nobody else in the world does
that's just purely from the
combinatorics of human dna and
development and so beca and so your goal
in life is to find out the people who
need you the most to find out the
business that needs you the most to find
the project and the art that needs you
the most because there's something out
there just for you
um but what you don't want to do is be
building checklists and decision
frameworks built on what other people
are doing because you're never going to
be there
you'll never be good at being with
somebody else
the other another idea that was
hugely useful to me
was that i listened in law school when
some wag said
a legal mind
is a mind that when two things are
all twisted up together
and interacting
it's feasible to think responsibly about
one thing and not the other
well i could see from that one sentence
that that was perfectly ridiculous
and it
pushed me further into my natural drift
which
was into
learning all the big ideas and all the
big disciplines so i wouldn't be a
perfect damn fool
who was trying
to think about
one aspect of something that couldn't be
removed from the totality of the
situation
in a constructive
fashion
and what i noted since the really big
ideas carry 95 of the freight that
wasn't at all hard for me to
pick up all the big ideas
in all the disciplines
and make them a standard part of my
mental routines
once you have the ideas of course
they're no good if you don't practice if
you don't practice you lose it
so i went through life constantly
practicing this
disciplinary approach well i can't tell
you what that's done for me
it's it's
it's it's made life more fun it's made
me more constructive it's maybe more
helpful to others it's made me
enormously rich
you name it that attitude really helps
and by the way when i talk about this
multidisciplinary
attitude
i'm really
following a very key idea of the
greatest lawyer of antiquity
marcus tullus cicero
and cicero is famous for saying
a man who doesn't know what happened
before he's born
goes through life like a child that is a
very correct idea of cicero's and he's
right
to ridicule
somebody so foolish as not to know what
happened before he was born
but if you generalize
cicero as i think one should
there are all these other things
that you should know in addition to
history
and those other things are the big ideas
in all the other disciplines and it
doesn't help you just to know them
enough so you could prattle them back on
an exam and get an a
you have to learn these things in such a
way
that they're in a mental lattice work in
your head and you automatically use them
for the rest of your life
if you do that i solemnly promise you
that
one day you'll be walking down the
street and
you look to your right and left you'll
think my heavenly days i'm now one of
the
few most competent people of my whole
age cohort
if you don't do it
many of the brightest of you will
live in the middle ranks or in the
shallows
another idea that i got
and it was encapsulated by that story
the
dean
recounted about the man who
wanted to know where he was going to die
and he wouldn't go that way go there
that rustic
who had that idea had a profound
truth
in his hand
the way
complex adaptive systems
work
and the way mental constructs work
problems
frequently get easy i i'd even say
usually are easier
to solve if you turn around and reverse
in other words if you want to help india
the question you should ask is now how
can i help india
you think
what's doing the worst damage in india
what will automatically do the worst
damage and how do i avoid it
you'd think they're logically the same
thing
they're not those of you who have
mastered algebra
know that inversion
frequently will solve problems which
nothing else
will solve and in life
unless you're
more gifted than einstein
inversion will help you solve problems
that you can't solve another way let me
use a little inversion now
what will really fail in life what do we
want to avoid
such an easy answer
sloth and onward reliability
if you're unreliable it doesn't matter
what your virtues are you're going to
create her immediately
so doing what you have faithfully
engaged to do
should be an automatic
part of your
conduct you want to avoid sloth on
unreliability
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you